hey everybody and welcome to an
incredible wild ride with stevo we have
got
one of the biggest stars on the planet
this week
i'm pretty sure i don't have to tell you
anything about him except
he's just about the nicest person i've
ever met just such a cool dude man
what an honor let's get into it ladies
and gentlemen
post malone what's going on party please
hell yeah [ __ ] so stoked man me too
this is uh the rolling in with a
bulletproof
beer koozie yeah this is the way you
know this is i haven't tested it out yet
i'd assume you know if you want full
protection
you have to hold your beer like this all
the time uh-huh but even then it'd knock
you out
because it would hit you i'm confused
as to how it works right like when is it
ever useful it's worth a try
though why would they make one like
what's the idea behind that r d like all
right let's make it
yeah it's just dope it is pretty badass
and then you have uh
you know has a nice little tactical
pouch here what do you keep in there
switchblade bottle opener that's ah
is it an allen wrench it's everything
this does everything
i like it that you want it to do wow i
don't know yeah i don't know you know
whatever
but it's badass it's definitely better
we're trying it out after
if you didn't have the koozie and it was
like
just bud light you know right that
bud light's okay with that yeah of
course yeah
yeah you know i had to bring my ads here
you had a bud light uh super bowl
commercial yeah
and you have the cooler in your house is
that just always stocked
ah it's outside now it still runs it is
technologically made very well
it's cold as [ __ ] but it's can i cuss on
here yeah of course
out of love for bud light we've made the
the light
it's perfect no you said you said you
know it was by accident it was
there's no accident right that's funny
because uh when you
i remember i asked you and i think when
you first started making money you
bought a refrigerator
it wasn't when i first started making
money it was right before i went to
rehab i bought a full-size
[ __ ] fridge like with uh
the freezer side was equal you know like
so
the freezer side was just nothing but
like [ __ ] vodka bottles just from
top to bottom like six feet tall and
then the right side was budweiser
you're a bud light guy bug's blood wiser
yeah but heavy what heavy
i think the bud light should be called
bud heavy because
it does have less alcohol well you know
it's like four percent alcohol versus
five percent on the uh
the bud like it sounds that way
technically you have to carry more bud
light you have to drink more bud light
and you have to pee more big
bud light we'll see but that you're
peeing more
you're then you're always in homeostasis
there
you don't have too much liquid yeah too
little liquid
but you know this is built for me it's
built for speed
um like shotgunning yeah shotguning why
not
beer funneling this is built and you
don't get too full
because i see people and i see people
too they go out and eat a whole goddamn
pizza
and then drink mugs of beer and i'm like
how how do you
how do you do that yeah it doesn't make
any sense
yeah so this keeps me kind of the bud
light or the bud heavy makes me too
full this keeps me right in perfect
equilibrium homeostasis i'm
so is your writer bud light it's bud
light
how many do you ask for per show as much
as they'll give me
really which is usually what probably a
lot yeah
they give us a lot i'm always so
fascinated with writers though like uh
is that is that all that's on your
writer no my writer is pretty normal
it's normal i just i don't care cheetos
doritos burritos
all the eatos yeah everything with it
because i love to eat
oh yeah stevo stevo
yeah stevo's on
i want to dive right into this [ __ ]
classic story
and and i got to tell you post i had
this idea
for the longest time i might have even
just gone and
said it like on the podcast but i had
the plan
the plan was that i wanted to put uh
wax on one of my eyebrows just one of my
eyebrows
where you put the wax and the paper i
wanted to have a string
tied to the wax where the string and
then is connected to a baseball
my idea was that you would be dressed up
as a
like like a baseball uniform like
whatever with like a
baseball bat and i would lob this
baseball over to you
with the string tied to it tonight you
would hit the baseball okay
right so the baseball goes [ __ ]
flying okay me specifically
yeah okay right i had the so the bass
so the baseball goes flying and brings
my eyebrow with
it right like so then now i've got no
eyebrow and then the idea would be
to tattoo like sort of a dick-shaped
eyebrow
okay like over it and and i just died
because because you're a prolific
famous like face tattoo guy and i'm like
if i'm going to get a [ __ ]
eyebrow dick tattoo like
imagine having post malone tattoo this
dick on my forehead
amazing sure so we're filming jackass
for
and i would never go as far as to like
give away
what we've done but i told the director
i was like you know what
have this [ __ ] idea up my sleeve and
i've just
i love you i love jackass [ __ ] if you
want it
i would absolutely love i would be
honored to do that right um
i've never i've hit a baseball off a tee
before
i've never hit a baseball uh in midair
um
director had a different idea that he
liked better for the eyebrow
coming off and it did get both of my
eyebrows off like
i was conspicuously missing eyebrows for
a little while there it looked like jeff
love for like a month so you've tried it
out
right we did it and we had you booked to
come and tattoo
a [ __ ] dick on my forehead and at the
last minute
for reasons that i'm not necessarily
clear about
like all of a sudden they just called it
off so you were like scheduled to come
tattoo a dick on my forehead for jackass
i'm not here i'm around
we got this
this is what we'll do and we can do this
tonight we'll tie the string
around the bullet and just shoot the
bullet
at the beer can yeah yeah okay and so
you get like a four
for one deal dude we and we have the
machines
we have the lights we have the
production crew
i'll get the dick on my forehead later
like you know i don't need to do that
now
but you want to take one eyebrow off now
ah dude i just grew my eyebrows back i
[ __ ]
i don't like not having it we'll figure
it out we'll make it work
we'll figure it out but here's the thing
man when i had no eyebrows
then all of a sudden i'm like okay we
had a dick drawing party for
thanksgiving dinner
it's interesting and then i realized
some people go around saying what
they're thankful for
dick drawing party right and and i'm
like why
did i [ __ ] make my eyebrows go off
because
the whole thing it's like then the
eyebrow grows back what is it that gonna
grow in and cover the dick
like in my view the reason for getting
the dick tattoo to my forehead
is to see how long i last before i'm
like [ __ ] i can't take anymore i tap out
or maybe i love it and i keep it forever
but if the eyebrow growing back now
covers up the dick
then it's then so really i just had it
all wrong and what i need
is the dick to be above my eyebrow
completely
on my forehead what about just like a
centerpiece
like a charles manson dick yeah oh
that's a nice
ball i got a head on yeah just like
straight oh yeah
or it could be like dripping jizz like a
teardrop like how tough you are dude you
can have you could have the balls come
around the
the eyes and the dick come down
these are your ideas yeah yeah i mean
but dude it was so cool
i love how it keeps getting just yeah
but here's the sad thing
about your whole world it just keeps
getting bigger and bigger and it's like
all of a sudden it just happens
i'm gonna have a dick on my forehead but
that but that doesn't need to happen
until later i couldn't believe that they
were down for it man
i mean how how long did you last with
your eyebrows shaved like were you just
so [ __ ] overwhelming
like there's nothing you can do about
that it's just when you wax off your
eyebrows it takes
so long to even start growing back yeah
but in any case dude this is gonna be
another one of those ones where they're
like this [ __ ] stevo
shut up like uh yeah so
we're we're in utah where we came out to
see you yeah
the most epic trip ever dude and just
what a bro you are man like
we knew that you were the nicest guy
ever and
like but that was the the perception was
like
that dude seems so nice but you really
are
so nice and like polite we're like what
a well-mannered young man
were you always like that or is it just
like the more famous you get the nicer
you become
i don't know i've met a lot of [ __ ]
in my [ __ ] life
and uh i try not to be one of them yeah
that's the
i always say the golden rule is don't be
a [ __ ] yeah i like it i mean
steve's trying to get a dick on his head
unless you're stevo
it's different yeah no i i i feel
very strongly the same way i think that
it's actually easier
to just be a nice person yeah it's
genuinely easier you sleep better you
yeah you think because and you know
there's a there's a bunch of times where
you're like
[ __ ] man like i could have taken a
picture with somebody and
you know like made their whole yeah week
or whatever and
but then i think about it all the time
i'm like [ __ ] man you know
i should have been better and i guess
you know that's the whole thing is just
trying to be better every day
do you have any rules because you must
have boundaries around like people
coming up asking for photos right like
so if you're eating dinner you have no
problem with people coming up i'll take
it
i mean i don't like the whole dinner
thing yeah yeah right but
it's okay i don't mind and i'm not gonna
be a doucher about it you know
right um but yeah i mean i don't need to
eat anyways
the problem comes when there's just too
many people right
yeah if it's if it's like a manageable
number of people then i agree you can
pretty much handle everything
but uh it but sometimes it's
if you're with other people like i'm
always with scott randolph
and we and we have a boundary where
people say hey will you take this
and i'm like yeah dude cause i'll be
taking like 70 80 photos a day
right and so we just like put on selfie
right here
and then we started a video called age
of the selfie yeah and so you know if
you're with it you just come up boom
boom yeah yeah that's the easiest way
it's easiest way you don't need like a
foot you don't need like a full fit pick
yeah unless you have like the most fire
shoes on right
yeah well you always got some steve
always matches very nicely with his vans
and his shoes and his outfit it's nice
you have you have you you got it you
have it
he's got the idiot have things like that
people being like
how they behave around you is that worse
in utah or better like because people in
hollywood sometimes are like
oh like oh there goes post malone like i
live in hollywood i'm used to that
right or is it is it the opposite like
how is it here i'd say you know i don't
know it's definitely
right it's different than here than in
hollywood where there's famous people
everywhere
you know what i mean but i don't know
some
people i mean people have been sweet
everywhere but i feel like people are
i guess maybe more scared to take a
photo and come up and say something
here right whenever you know i'm not
gonna like
yeah you know no one's gonna like [ __ ]
you up for coming and asking for a photo
but
i just think that's like that's the
difference there in hollywood they'll
just be like yeah look
or they'll just walk up to you and be
like like that anyways they're filming
you across the room or whatever yeah
that's the thing i don't like well you
lived in hollywood for a long while did
you not you just didn't like it at all
i don't know it's not my vibe yeah it's
not constructive how long ago did you
move here to utah
a couple of years okay we got to move we
should move out of course
move here oh you know it would be
perfect i'm getting some acres
like out of town you guys should just
build a house on there and you can do
dumb [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time i love it
just pimp it out those boxable houses
are so cool
and they're so easy to set up and it's
like you just order it on amazon
that's so cool yeah yeah dude i like
that so what made you decide utah you're
just like the
the shittiest weather and the hottest
chicks i'll go there is that right no
i don't know the women here are gorgeous
no but um
i i did a show here right this is a
this was
is that wendy yeah
but i did a show here there was supposed
to be it's like right on the salt lake
and there's supposed to be like 5 000
people and then like 17
000 people showed up and it was awesome
and
i was like [ __ ] it i'm i'm trying to get
out of the lane i found
the perfect place to do it yeah dude
what was the jump like for you because
it was
steve when i toured with steve
and we were doing you know comedy clubs
and then we got elevated to theaters did
you skip
theaters like did you start a smaller
venues and all of a sudden you're just
selling out
massive no we did
like we did we did shows
300 like 300 cap
smaller shows for a long time or
for a good amount of time yeah then i i
went
on tour with fatty wap and then justin
bieber invited me on tour um
and then we went on that tour and then
that [ __ ] was just crazy
so then we just kept jumping like you
know house of rock
is that what that's called house of
blues house of blues yeah i'm thinking
of jack
um yeah house of blues and [ __ ] and then
from there just
i guess just kept going and going after
festivals
really helped and then you know now we
do
the basketball places and the hockey
places arena basketball plays yeah
stadiums yeah the basketball place
madison square garden
msg was awesome two nights that's pretty
good
what's that capacity is that i made it
like
i think it's like 18 no no no that's
like way more right
it is it less than i feel that
basketball
wrap around the whole thing yeah i don't
i don't know i don't necessarily think
it's the biggest venue i think it's like
000. that's just kind of like i'd be in
the gold standard
but yeah that's you know that's that
that was [ __ ] awesome
what do you prefer life on the road or
life at home
i love to play games and the wi-fi sucks
on the bus
so you're like your homebody yeah i
most definitely am but i love going out
and doing shows and meeting fans and
and there's nothing like being up on
stage and everybody's singing the same
shitty song
you know what i mean how crazy is that
pretty good stuff where you just like
hold the mic out and everybody's just
you're like what the [ __ ] that's pretty
well i usually do that that's the trick
is you do that when you're out of breath
because i'm a chunky boy
you guys just do it man what's your
workout routine on the road just 12
hours
well i definitely especially now i got i
can't even imagine going on tour right
now because
a i forgot all the words of my songs
b i'm you know i'm putting them on every
day and
the only thing that gets a workout is my
fingers i was gonna say my hands but
somebody might get the wrong idea about
that
how often does that happen though that
you you make a song
because like i make music and sometimes
it's like you just like said something
one like you recorded it and that became
the song
yes sir and like you don't even remember
it the next day like would it sound like
do you have to go back and like
learn your own lyrics sort of like well
that's the whole [ __ ] deal like it's
i'll forget i probably have some
semi-decent songs that are just will
never
be anything because that's how we do it
in a night we'll make like
five or six songs but none of them will
have words but they'll all be arranged
with melody
and [ __ ] but then like i'll forget that
that song exists and then like
four or three years later i'll come back
to it and be like oh this song's really
good like let's
do something with this that's the whole
yeah it's too much [ __ ] to keep
up with like sure you know quavo like we
were in the studio and we got this great
mic
so it's like a wireless mic that just
hooks up to the interface
and you can just sit there and [ __ ]
around like with your friends over pro
tools
and we sat there we made like 14 songs
and i'm just now going over them now
wow like yeah we were all on shrooms and
chugging beers and it was it was great
yeah you might and then you just don't
remember the night then you wake up
you're like dude that was [ __ ] fine
i was like we made songs last night
right and then oh lose like he sends me
like 14 songs
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah you know dude epic
how about ozzy ozzy osbourne man
he's always been a hero to me i love
ozzy
you know what else i love i love boning
my girl
yeah i said it i love boning my girl and
i love when i have an
extra rock hard boner and you know what
gives me that
truly blue chew tablets man when i tried
these things just for fun
i couldn't believe how well they
actually worked what is a bluetooth
tablet
well it's a tablet that's got the same
active ingredient as both
viagra and cialis except it's chewable
delicious and costs just a fraction of
the price
and getting them is so easy man you just
go online
there's no awkward doctor visit in
person
no you go online to their website and
you consult with one of their medical
providers
and boom you you're good to go your
tablets will show up in the mail in a
couple days you know what's even better
than that
it's the deal that i'm going to give you
right now oh man and if you're a fan of
the wild ride podcast
and if you're a dude who likes to bone
and if you want
a free month supply of these bluetooth
tablets
then do this go to bluetooth.com
do the deal sign up man at checkout you
use the promo code stevo
a whole month's supply of bluetooth
tablets completely for free
all you have to pay is five dollars for
shipping and again
if you're a fan of the podcast and if
you're a fan of boning
do this do this for me do this for you
do this for the love of god okay
and enjoy boning because man these
things gave me a rock hard boner and now
i use them regularly
all right let's talk about ozzy ozzy's
incredible
dude that was uh that was a big deal huh
yeah it was really really [ __ ]
awesome i'm i was happy that he was uh
down with it you know and then we did
another song together which is awesome
but
he's just a [ __ ] beast man that's the
coolest [ __ ]
dude yeah ozzy's my [ __ ] hero dude do
you have other legends that you still
hope to like would be so cool to do a
song with
that guy i got some more [ __ ] going
on right now i can't i'm not at liberty
to discuss yeah they'll send somebody to
kill me but there's some cool [ __ ] going
on cool
i believe here's like how my experience
has
been since hanging out with post or even
like mentioning oh we're gonna go to
utah and
you know like hang out with post like as
soon as
every single person who uh i say that to
here's it
they're like oh dude i gotta [ __ ]
collab with them i wanted to [ __ ]
you know like like even knoxville
like like when knoxville was like oh
dude i wanted to record something for
for something yeah no no like the
it's crazy you know it's insane yeah
it's crazy
and and i actually heard somebody say
that uh
that like oh yeah that you moved to utah
because you got tired of being in la
like where you've just felt everybody
wanted to use you for something well
yeah that's how it goes there's a lot of
people
and i can't speak on behalf of everybody
right but there's a lot of people there
that just
care about their own personal growth and
everything else and we'll [ __ ] on you
to to achieve it you know what i mean
did you feel like that coming up steve i
mean i don't know like
like this there's not even a comparison
for for me at any point in my career
to to wear person you know
like it's it's evident that like post
malone's a big [ __ ] deal but you're
the toughest dude on the planet well
thanks man ah vince is crazy like that
but you had like
fair-weathered friends for sure you know
oh yeah of course
but the idea of like everybody you know
like when you just asked is does does
post have
like a dream collab you know like is
there a dream legend who you'd love to
collab with
and in my mind i'm thinking dude it's
like
himself i didn't want anybody
he's the dream collab whoever posts
dream collab is
is dreaming of posting with right right
right they should be so lucky
that's it's it's [ __ ] cool to think
about and you know i think it's just
like
it's not because i'm necessarily
good or anything it's nothing it's that
it's like
to be down for for everything and to
genuinely have an appreciation
of every of everything in in the
you know in music and that's the cool
thing i feel like
that's what it is because a lot of
people take things way too seriously or
just do features because like
you know someone's popping or something
you know as opposed to like
oh [ __ ] it we'll just sit down in the
studio and just [ __ ] around for hours
and see where it goes you never [ __ ]
know
and that's the cool part because you can
make awesome [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
anything
yeah in in in high school you were voted
most likely to succeed
i think so it was either like most
beautiful
yeah this is not the truth but yeah i
think it was i think it was that
or best dressed i had these penny
loafers that i was just [ __ ] up
really yeah that's cool what do you
think it was about you that they could
tell
then like this dude's going places were
you sort of like already
making [ __ ] and well i don't i was doing
like you know i was doing like
stadiums in high school yeah this is
selling out
i was in high school yeah my dad worked
at a t so he just smuggled me in
gymnasiums dude i played att stadium
no one was [ __ ] there but i did it
um no yeah i was already doing like
they would give me like 100 something
box and a free chicken parmesan at the
the italian restaurant on main street
and i was like as a high school kid
you're like [ __ ] yeah this is
[ __ ] and um
uh just making music
i made like a full mixtape
everything i wrote songs made like edm
[ __ ] and just [ __ ] around and played
it for everybody all my friends who
wanted to listen to it
and that was the cool part is like
having
people ask for the song so i was like
sending
to my friends and [ __ ] and and uh
that was the cool part and you know
playing my [ __ ] at like the parties and
[ __ ] it was cool
you know that's cool white out uh
what iverson yeah did you know that was
gonna blow up
before you dropped it no sir you had no
idea
i was this that was the coolest [ __ ] and
uh
key from atlanta was really the catalyst
of that but like
hi baby wendy you're gonna need to
turn it down
no we just [ __ ] put it out and i woke
up and then mac miller and
and whiz and and you're broke as [ __ ]
yeah most definitely broke his back yeah
and i'm also so that's where you blow up
and at that point do you have any face
tattoos no i do not i have no tattoos
so how old were you when you blew up i
just
like just turned 19 i think jeez
well okay yeah i want to get back to the
face tattoos but i'm always so [ __ ]
fascinated with
what you have no money right all of a
sudden you get money
what's the first thing you buy just for
a second let's forget about
having a lot of money and making a big
purchase
and let's consider not needing much
money at all
to make an important purchase what's an
important purchase i'm telling you right
now
expressvpn what's vpn
it's virtual private network why is that
important
because you know what when i get on
wi-fi and i connect
i'm excited and then i see unsecured
network
and it stresses me out man i don't like
it because i know that means that people
are
are invading my privacy maybe even
stealing from me man
all this stuff going on i don't want to
worry about it you know what the
solution is is
expressvpn because they provide a
private secure and encrypted surfing
experience
you know what else rules about them they
hide your ip address man
so you become completely anonymous when
you're online
your browsing history whatever
weird stuff you're going to check out
nobody needs to know about it man
plus you know what else in other
countries they're making
super awesome content like for example
in england their doctor who is amazing
but if you're in america you go to try
and check it out all of a sudden
you're in the wrong country yeah well
not anymore man not with expressvpn
you can be in pretty much any country
you want
you can consume content from all over
the globe
and nobody knows where you're at and
nobody's invading your privacy
and nobody's stealing from you and that
is a sweet deal
but the deal is going to get even
sweeter because right now i'm going to
hook you up
with three extra months of service
completely for free
if you go to expressvpn.com
stevo yeah man stop with all the
giving people your info business letting
them steal from you
no no no no become anonymous
become private and encrypted and enjoy
content from all over the world
and have three extra months for free one
more time by going to expressvpn.com
stevo yeah you're welcome
now let's hear about post malone's big
purchases
i remember when i signed my deal
with the republic because that's where
all the money came from i didn't have i
had like
you know they would give me like a
thousand bucks for a show yeah but
as a first money i i bought an s550
and a watch what's an s550 the mercedes
okay sick yeah what kind of watch is a
rolex a rolex
presidential yes sir yeah but it had the
nice
uh the flooded bezel this is important
because i was like i never had a [ __ ]
diamond in my [ __ ] life
and it's uh a rolex bezel no oh you got
the aftermarket right yeah
okay yeah yeah then i was just like give
me [ __ ]
give me the diamonds right right right
now now as you know i've grown up i
if you have diamonds they have to be
factory which is important
you know right yeah yeah i've grown up
now you gotta have a rolex time well
yeah well that's
you need the rolex down yes because it's
very obvious
it's an investment you know like i used
to
you know you know the bus downs are cool
they look great you know they look great
but then
you took your watch and then now [ __ ]
if you ever want to get rid of it and
get another watch you've knocked off
tens of thousands of dollars off of the
watch
and just you know so now now it's just
like
the patek diamonds are patek diamonds
the
the rolex diamonds are rolex and
but usually i like you know i'm a more
laid-back guy you know
yeah i'm just like playing jane now you
know what
what watch you got on now nothing no
watch it's just a bracelet
yeah dude so i haven't worn a watch in
a long time i don't need to present
myself you know i i had a i had a
the really nice watch that you gave me
and i was like wearing it and my buddy's
like what time is it and i pulled out my
iphone to look at the cloud
he's like bro you have this nice watch
you're telling me the time on your
iphone you can't keep up especially if
you're traveling you're like [ __ ] it's
an hour back isn't that right
yeah oh yeah that doesn't do anything
right yeah like daylight savings and
[ __ ] but i can't keep up with that
so so your first face tattoo was always
tired
no what was my first face tattoo
the smiley face okay it looks like a
marshmallow face like the dj marshmallow
i just wanted it to be a drunk guy but
then
my friends are like oh is that a
marshmallow tattoo and i'm like no i do
i like marshmallow enough but did you i
would not get
his face tattooed on me when you started
with the face tattoos
i mean like you just blew up now you're
like [ __ ]
killing it in your career and next thing
you know you got a face tattoo
is your like team of representatives
just freaking out like
what are you doing no i don't tell them
so they just have to deal with it yeah
whatever
right whatever happened and uh i mean it
just it seems like
at this certain point when you blow up
then all of a sudden you have something
to lose
and you're like [ __ ] i'm gonna tap my
face up and all it did was just make you
blow up more well yeah that's the whole
thing i've always wanted to do it
because i'm
nothing special to look at like i don't
have the jawline of you guys
there's no i don't have this not me them
too i don't have the salt and pepper of
steve
say something nice about the piercing
blue eyeliner the
the epic
oh come on you mustache listen to your
shirt what do you got going on
nothing nothing good it's smooth it's
just smooth that's all right
dude but that's what people are in i
would never lift up my shirt dude
yeah dude i wish there was something
impressive
like i'm fascinated by it and uh dude
just [ __ ] kudos for
you know yeah i think it's cool it's
almost like you sort of represent this
like
chaotic freedom that people just like
you know it's it's just a good feeling
that you sort of give off
you know like uh and i'm impressed too
that you kept this level head
you seem pretty level-headed and like
from blowing up at 19 that
seems almost impossible like what's the
kind of secret to that is that like
good family good close friends like a
good crew like
yeah what do you think i i i'd attribute
it to to bo
like you know good friends good family
like
every i guess being raised right and it
goes back to that [ __ ] rule just
don't be a dick because like
you know dicks get
places you know what i mean like if you
step
on somebody to get to somewhere
you might achieve it but then like at
the end of the night either
you're gonna not be able to [ __ ]
sleep and you're going [ __ ] crazy and
[ __ ] like that but you know i don't know
it's just like all of a sudden you start
developing a nervous tick and you're
like
yeah dude i wonder why i have a nervous
ticket because you're probably a
[ __ ] somewhere else just
coming up i'm terrified of like
i just i don't know i believe in like
just the
the universe and being in in like
harmony with it you know like
my buddy uh tommy who's who's with us
he's you know
i've known him for almost 30 years we're
all sober dudes we work like you know
this program of recovery
which is all about just not being a dick
is basically it
and uh you know like when every time i
get stressed out about something i think
something's going to go wrong and i'd
say to tommy like [ __ ]
he's like dude the force is with us you
know and what he's saying the
force is with us like if you're doing
the right thing you're treating people
right
right it's gonna work out you know for
sure
and i think that that's just a good way
to look at it
but at the same time too you know you're
saying uh you know everybody
like uh wants to use you for something
every like
but we were down to drive all the way
from l.a
yeah we earned it
not you
it was a huge [ __ ] uh
it's just a huge honor to be able to cut
to come
with you i'm [ __ ] honored for you
guys
thank you so much man and and like i
didn't even mind like
kind of giving away like what it even is
that we're doing here but it started
with uh doing the podcast with violent
jay from
insane clown posse yeah right and like
we had this wonderful conversation
and uh i decided hey man like you know
because the fbi made
you know juggalos the fans of icp an
official gang
like i want to join the game right so i
said what do i got to do to join the
gang and violent chases oh yeah i gotta
get a [ __ ] hatchet man tattoo are you
a fugitive right now are you
no they're not what happens if you show
a cop you're tattooing
i don't know but yeah i got so i got my
gang tattooed yeah buddy
and then and and it's part of this like
tattoo project where like you know i got
into giving tattoos and i'm like oh [ __ ]
man i want to make a project where i'm
driving around this rv
giving people tattoos and so like i said
to scott man let's go on a trip where
should we go
and uh scove was like well how about we
[ __ ]
like try to go hang with post malone in
utah i'm like all right so
because we had you scheduled to shoot
with us for jackass
like uh yeah our jackass people had your
your people's contacts
so i was like i got the contact i
reached out and i was like yeah i'm
doing this tattoo thing i just got a
juggalo tattoo
i send the picture to your buddy bobby
and he sends me
a [ __ ] photo of you wearing an a
hatchet man
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] jersey yeah they're
great dudes they said they sent that all
over and i i was happy to have it it's
brilliant
they're both maxing out in the nice
department and
uh and violent jay another person i told
violent j yeah we're going to go [ __ ]
hang out with post
i read you his texts it was like i'll
capture a [ __ ]
i'll go to canada and capture bigfoot
and tame it and deliver it to you on a
leash
if you can talk post into collabing with
me
holy [ __ ] dude not knowing not knowing
how hard it would be
because bigfoot's interdimensional yeah
dude speaking of which i don't know if
we're getting off subject but you're
going to skinwalker ranch soon
yeah dude and now i'm like why did i
just [ __ ]
say what i should do that would violent
jade didn't [ __ ]
that was a private text
don't attack stevo that's the lesson
because he's gonna tell [ __ ]
everybody
can we talk about this skinwalker ranch
because you guys were talking about it
last night i've never
really heard about it watch that watch
the movie yeah
i need to it's on and then you ever
listen to coast to coast a.m
but george nori they always talk about
skinwalker ranch and different like
stories that happened there
are you spending the night i'm trying to
that would be ideal
and it's a you should just go so you
should
do that for jackass just go to skin and
do some
i wouldn't be able to they locked me in
an addict and i kicked a hole through
the drywall because i'm scared of ghosts
like
hey at our warehouse in a business
no no no that's how much i don't want to
be everything
i can't wait to put that footage out
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious
but dude you just went ghost hunting is
that right i go
i go enough it's go signings so dude
that makes like our tattoo exchange
even more oh yeah [ __ ] meaningful
yeah [ __ ] yeah
i love i love that what hasn't what you
you ever seen any ghosts yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah what have you seen i've
seen a lot of [ __ ] it's a lot of [ __ ]
there
i used to there used to be a house
that i used to go whenever i was a kid
that was like i'm so
serious dead serious the most haunted
[ __ ] place in the [ __ ]
world that i've been but that's what got
me [ __ ] started in that and then
i got in with zach baggins and [ __ ] and
such a sweet dude and
going like you know from ghost
adventures and and going
on [ __ ] ghost adventures and that's
just [ __ ]
and then opening up debit boxes and
getting in car wrecks and
almost plane wrecks and having bite
marks on my [ __ ] arm
you had bite marks on your arm yeah when
you woke up or something yes sir
well no i was sitting i didn't even
notice it when i woke up but i'm sitting
here
and then i'm looking at my arm and i'm
like who the [ __ ]
bit me because you could see the
individual teeth it looked like a small
like a kid's mouth
like right here on my arm and it was
like all bruised and [ __ ] but you could
see the individual teeth and i'm like
who could have bit me and i'm like
[ __ ] nobody has bit me
so it's uh it's crazy it's really really
weird
i was sleeping one night in san clemente
and i and uh
i heard something walk up the stairs and
just slap me in the butt and i woke
up and it was gone i really felt
something slapping in the butt really
hard
this was like ten years ago dude and i'm
like this you know
or i've been peeing somewhere and i felt
fingers go across my back
how come it always has to do with your
nether regions
i don't know i think you have an incubus
on your hands isn't that the demon yeah
the demon girl that
tries to get pregnant by you oh that's
and make you have a demon baby yeah i
think uh we're summoning them just
talking about them right now
i'm just saying nightmares like i
[ __ ]
like post malone and i tattooed
ghosts onto each other you're still
tripping out i [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
dude sorry about mine
i did i love it the lines are a little
shaky but
it's just extra creepy yeah you were
possessed by this yeah
he's like what happened he blacked out
he was like
like just pitch the ghost tattoo and
then i don't even realize
like [ __ ] it's ghost malone yeah
dude perfect you like that yeah that's
perfect it's it look i mean it
it sums me up perfectly that's it there
are no accidents
dude come on man look at your work look
at it it's great
dude epic it's totally up
how many times how many tattoos have you
given i said ten yesterday it's probably
ten
probably ten yeah yeah yeah yeah what
was your first one
i think it was either it was either a
slice of watermelon or a slice of pizza
they
it looked the same it could be
interpreted
either way who would you do that to i
think i'm my friend bobby
nice yeah bobby's such a good dude man
i'm really
really stoked it's surprising to me
yesterday when you were saying like it's
been so long since
you got it since you got a ted right but
and then we were talking about how like
when you started getting tattoos like
there was like a year
like most of this happened within like
the same year right or something like
that i think that's the best way
well not the best way but the way it
went for me mm-hmm but it just kept
going and going and going i was like i
need to get tattooed
but like i was saying too it hurts way
more [ __ ] now that i have all these
tattoos like every tattoo gets worse and
worse
yeah you got a soft hand though oh well
thanks man scott doesn't think so i gave
him one the other day and he was a real
[ __ ] about it
yeah they're just bragging on me
i'm your toughest client so so dude like
maybe this is a controversial topic but
i i i was
pretty interested uh
i'm interested to ask you about when you
were with
my buddy ethan yeah and you had to have
told ghost stories for the h3 podcast
yeah we told ghost stories and ethan
just uh
he said he's he just i guess this was
like yesterday or the day before he said
he was sad because we don't
talk anymore oh yeah and it's so funny
you mentioned him i just got his number
back again so i'm gonna text him tonight
he's
he's an incredible guy and he is the
most amazing person
yeah i i [ __ ] love that dude man um
and uh so if i get the story correctly
correct me if i'm wrong
um you're you're hanging out with ethan
and
like you guys are talking about jake
paul and then you just come up with this
idea oh it'll be funny i'll go on
jake paul's like website and buy some of
his merch
i wanted the merch it was good it was
like a god church
it was cool selling like a goddamn right
right that was his
lyric jake paul had a rap song at the
time i remember this now
yeah right he's just selling merch like
a god church yeah oh god
but you know what a god church is it's
like a church of god
like another kind of church church is
chicken
right that's the only other kind but
this one's about god
it's not a chicken church right okay
it's not the chicken church okay
and uh and so i presumably the podcast
with ethan goes out so jake paul is
aware
that you have now purchased money from
his website i think
maybe yeah this is probably how it
happened so then jake paul goes into
his like orders whatever and he he
manages to figure out which order was
actually yours
right so now he has your home address
right and then he decides he decides now
i'm gonna make a video
where i personally deliver the merch
that post malone ordered for my website
to post one's house myself i'm gonna
videotape the whole thing
so that when i put out the video i have
now like released to the world
exactly where post malone lives so he
essentially
docks to you yeah well i mean you know
and that's i'm sitting there playing
[ __ ] games someone knocks in the door
i'm like who the [ __ ] is that
and you open up the door and it's jake
[ __ ] paul bear
he's got the footage of you opening up
the door
and you know here's the whole thing you
know i don't know necessarily
but i had to talk with him when like we
talked about that whole thing
like i don't remember where we were but
he was there and then
after the fact like this was after the
fact and we talked about the whole thing
and
it was just like you know that wasn't
cool and he's like yeah i know that
wasn't cool but
you know i as of now you know whatever
whatever the [ __ ] is going on or
whatever but you know
we're we're on level grounds there so
you don't seem like the kind of a guy
who holds a grudge
it depends on what you do that's not
such a bad deal you know
he i think he had the best intent at
heart
or just the best content you know that
yeah
yeah he wanted the time to come i just
like i just know that
i i was particularly fascinated by that
whole story
because my girl and i don't want anyone
[ __ ] knowing where i live i don't
want anybody showing up my [ __ ] house
dude like i'll be the nicest guy in the
world you meet me in public but dude if
you start showing up at my house
like don't expect me to be the least bit
nice it's not
no [ __ ] sense of humor i don't want
your mail i don't want you [ __ ] at my
house
and my girl is like way even more my
girl is like super paranoid
like if we're filming in the house she's
got paul who edits all the footage like
i'll blur every like
[ __ ] that you could never read she's
like our address might be on there
somewhere you know so i'm just
really sensitive to what was what was
the aftermath for you did a lot of
people show up at your house and like no
nobody really and i lived on a pretty
like
this is i didn't have so much money so i
had so much money
yeah i didn't have so much money i lived
in like
like a two-bedroom
in utah in l.a in l.a this is i lived in
tarzana
ooh um this was only a couple years ago
right
the but i mean i had the money i just
had the lease for
he didn't have so much money now he's
got more money than [ __ ] well
i mean i'm thinking at that time you had
a [ __ ] ton of money
well i had the lease i didn't want to
break my lease
that's nothing to break your lease i
like to save but i also like to
spend it's an internal struggle that's
right
i mean dude like i'm i'm
collecting p for uh i'm trying to say
it's incredible
transition yeah
the internal struggle is that if i were
to save money
like if i were to be as careful about
saving my money
as i am about saving my pee right now
i would be way more wealthy can i see
the job
yeah within reach yeah yeah this is the
one i'm working on
oh my god we have i mean how
are you close to the goal yeah we've got
106 gallons of pea at my house
and uh i'm working towards 157 but i'm
gonna want some extras
well what are you gonna do with 157
specifically 157 yeah
can you talk about it i'll [ __ ] say
when it's my idea i don't care
um i have a kiddie pool
uh which has 157 gallons to get to the
fill line
and then you've got 13 inches deep so i
want to do the highest
belly flop ever performed into pure piss
are you going to call guinness really
yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm going to call guests
you should get posts pee while we're
here
the timing is such that it was a couple
years ago when that happened with jake
paul
and it was also a couple years ago that
he moved to utah
was that like part of it or did the
lease
it was because the lease was over and
you're like okay now i'm done yeah it
wasn't necessary
it didn't have anything to do with that
really so you click make something like
jake paul gets post malone to move the
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but now here's the back to bud
here's the thing dude like and it was
after this too
like jake paul hit me up and he was like
hey man i'm making a rap video
like you want to have a cameo in it and
i just thought
and it was just rad to see the way that
he operates
you know like he's just like there's
i just was just too curious not to do it
you know and uh
i did have like sort of thoughts after
the fact like oh dude
i'm like you know like now am i like
gonna be on the outs with ethan yeah
i'm sure like it's not as bad whenever i
went on ethan and that guy
was like saying all that weird [ __ ] do
you remember the guy who made like
uh patrice his name's patrice patrice
o'neill
no but he was like like calling like
and we were on the show and he was like
i'm watching you like
just wait just do you remember that i
don't know i was ethan about that and i
and i uh it was like
that was some weird stuff but
yeah it's different i don't know you
know i can't
i can't tell and it's not necessarily my
place
but i feel like you know nowadays
content is like king like you'll do
[ __ ] you know you'll do anything for
content sure
yeah but but i generally am like
i i victimize myself for content right
right as is it opposed when it comes to
others it's different
right right i think that like me and all
my jackass buddies
we've always been pretty good about like
being the brunt of
ourselves and not like [ __ ] with
other but that and that and that's the
whole thing like
as a whenever you show up to somebody's
house you know that's good
that's for that's for something else but
i mean i've
you got to feel like he knows oh if i do
this i'm going to look bad but i'm also
gonna get
this right uh you know attention in this
way
and it's not always necessary i don't
know it's different i think that that uh
jake paused like the heel of the
internet like the yeah he's like the
randy orton
yeah you know the the the wrestler the
who else is a good heel everybody was a
heel at once
covington from the ufc do you like ufc
i like ufc yeah dad love that [ __ ] i
like ufc i got max holloway is the
nicest [ __ ] dude
in the universe he loves video games too
you guys just get along great why'd you
smack him in ufc
two ufc two you play ufc
ufc 2 is the best one why you got it no
i'll smack anybody on this [ __ ] bus
ufc 3
was not good your c2 is is the one
that's the one where that's the one
where you just like you could all have
full health full stamina
but you just dodged once and rocked the
[ __ ] and he just dropped
so dude but this one the next one they
had three they have like health bars
yeah that's pretty cool you think you
can beat me at guitar hero too
yes
because i'm like that was street fighter
i'm like dude i will [ __ ] up anybody on
this bus right
so dude the ufc video game is like uh
ultimate fighter or whatever
video game where it's like you're you're
you're in love and then you just beat
them up and then
they explode well that's like that's
exploded street fighter is that
that's yeah that's street fighter but
yeah ufc game the ufc
uc2 was so good because this was
it was like you don't always want to
throw it was like a real fight where you
like circle the [ __ ] and think about
what's going on
chess match dude and then just wait and
then you [ __ ] rock this kid once with
uh over him yeah you just rock this
[ __ ]
and then he's out one shot and then you
just get on top and [ __ ] hammer fist
the [ __ ] out of him
and then it's over is that are you
playing you're playing ufc now
right now i used to for tour we used to
are you playing any video games
currently are you
are you on the magic tip i'm playing
magic
rust mordhow i play clone hero if you
want to play guitar here i'll show you
what's like
i'll play this ingva mom's team
i've never really played i mean i used
to play in the back in the day but like
you're an expert you could play expert
level and those are the guys that are
just like
how do you even see that
i couldn't play right now i can play
some [ __ ] right now i'm
i'm getting up there i'm making you piss
i'm bit i'm your
first yeah i love it what did i tell you
nicest guy ever and he might
have contributed one of the largest
single pisses
that exists in my over 190 gallon
collection of piss in the front yard
and if you haven't seen the the new
video on my main
channel then maybe you don't know what
it's for
well get on over there and check it out
yeah dude what else man say hi to my
buddy zach
dad you guys don't even know what a
[ __ ] star this
kid's gonna be [ __ ]